there is no federal election law
violation here I just got done
interviewing the former head of the
Federal Election Commission under Bill
Clinton okay and this person said it's
very clear under the best argument for
Alvin Breck that this was not a federal
election law violation even if
everything Alvin Bragg alleges is true
even if Donald Trump David pecker of the
National Enquirer and Michael Cohen
Trump's lawyer sat down and said we have
three potential stories coming out about
you how can we get rid of them let's
capture and kill them here's a slush
fund to pay off these people Eve is true
not an election contribution that would
have to be reported and so on it's a
personal expense it was paid from Donald
Trump's personal account and it just
doesn't qualify so there's no underlying
crime